e
[Música]
y la ilusión de la estabilidad la
estabilidad es una frivolidad mención a
carlos monsiváis y haciendo memoria
resulta que en esta aparente estabilidad
me pongo a ver como en una película casi
toda mi vida y comienza con el
nacimiento posteriormente como somos
seres estables pasamos a la primaria
terminan la primaria pasas a la
secundaria después a la preparatoria
luego a la universidad si se puede la
maestría al doctorado y en este trayecto
de vida tienes que ver el tener una
pareja estable con hijos con una casa
con un seguro y una vida feliz hasta tu
jubilación y lo que sigue
pareciera que esa es la idea que quieren
vendernos desde hace muchos años sobre
lo que debería de ser una vida estable
qué es lo que ocurre
que en ese trayecto y a estos 33 escasos
años de vida
me cuestiono si la estabilidad realmente
existe o es solo una ilusión que
quisieran vendernos para no adaptarnos a
la realidad y cuál es esa realidad que
como seres humanos no podemos ser
estables porque vivimos en un cambio
constante algo que no nos dicen en este
trayecto de primaria secundaria
preparatoria universidad matrimonio
hijos nietos etcétera es todo lo que
ocurre en el día a día en ese largo
caminar por ejemplo no nos dicen qué
pasa cuando no quedas en la escuela o en
la carrera que había elegido
no nos dicen qué pasa cuando ya no
puedes pagar tu casa
tus estudios
no nos dicen cómo afrontar que en ese
trayecto haya personas que se vayan haya
decepciones
o haya muertes
qué pasará con nosotros los seres
humanos que nos educan para hacernos
castillos en el aire sobre algo que no
nos enseñan cómo afrontar
en este camino recordé a una historia
que hace mucho tiempo me llamó bastante
la atención y se trataba de un reino que
estaba en guerra y se hablaba de que el
rey era un hombre suficientemente
sanguinario para destruir lo que se
pusiera a su paso
cuando él tenía prisioneros los llamaba
a su corte y los dejaba elegir la forma
de morir tienen dos opciones morir a
manos de mis arqueros delante de toda mi
corte
o atreverse a pasar esa puerta
cabe mencionar que nadie en el reino
sabía que había detrás de esa puerta
todos por temor a conocer lo que había
detrás preferían morir a lo seguro en
manos de los arqueros sin mayores
sufrimientos
cuando el primer ministro le pregunta
una vez terminada la guerra majestad
qué hay detrás de la puerta
velo por ti mismo
este hombre empieza a abrir la puerta
que tenía figuras horribles y comienza a
ver que entra a un pequeño rayo de luz
que se hacen más y más y más grande y
encuentra un pequeño camino que conducía
a las afueras del reino
en el camino de la libertad
por qué será
que a muchos de nosotros no nos educan
para amar esa libertad y ojo la libertad
no puede estar encadenada
implica un cambio constante yo te
aseguro que no eres el mismo de ayer de
hace una hora o de hace cinco minutos
que acabas de escuchar lo que yo te
estoy diciendo
somos seres cambiantes
y cada cambio
implica una evolución
haciendo remembranza a uno de mis libros
favoritos que es el viejo y el mar de
ernest hemingway recuerdo un pasaje
bastante interesante y bastante vivido
en donde está el viejo en la inmensidad
del mar y una vez que agarra el pez
empieza a apretar fuertemente la cuerda
y era una lucha hombre pese y mencionaba
el viejo las manos me duele
pero no puedo soltarlo
por qué entonces seguiría lo que le
estoy aferrando
cuántos de nosotros
como yo sigo aferrada a ideas a
creencias y pensamientos oa ilusiones
sin ver que la vida en este cambio
constante me va a ir poco a poco
mostrando el camino al cual me debo
adaptar
como vivo con la plenitud del cambio si
no hay una estabilidad
y es que curiosamente a lo largo de la
vida ya como nos han educado desde el
principio de los tiempos es que tenemos
que poseer algo por lo menos la certeza
de que nos encontramos estables
aun cuando no sea cierto
tenemos avances tecnológicos y tenemos
muchos aparatos que van cambiando
constantemente y yo me pregunto nosotros
en este cambio constante cuando nos
atreveremos a aceptar que tenemos que ir
cambiando y adaptándonos a la vida
para finalizar hay algo que a mí me
llama mucho la atención porque la vida
no es una constante de repente hay altas
de repente hay bajas como en los latidos
del corazón
a veces estás arriba y a veces estás
abajo simplemente te pido que pienses en
este momento aquellos instantes en los
que te has sentido completamente pleno o
en los que te has sentido completamente
vacío y es un subir y bajar y subir y
bajar
porque asocio la vida y estos cambios al
latido del corazón porque cuando
hablamos de estabilidad
estás muerto muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]